Brad Baron [singing]:
"Back together again, You can say you knew us when,
We were together, now we’re apart,
Brad Baron [singing]:
Thunder and lightning are back in my heart,
And that’s the weather to be,
Brad Baron [singing]:
When you’re back together with me."
Olivia Stoker:
Hi, I’m Olivia Stoker.
Brad Baron:
and I’m Brad Baron
Olivia Stoker:
We’re both the class of 2011 and right now we’re sitting on the set
of 'The House of Blue Leaves' by John Guare at the Berlind Theater
Brad Baron:
And this our theater certificate acting thesis.
Olivia Stoker:
Tracy Bersley is the director, we’re just so thankful to have.
Brad Baron:
I’m Artie Shaughnessy. He is 45 years old.
He is a struggling musician in New York City, he writes songs, and
Brad Baron:
he’s running out of chances, and he’s starting to get a little desperate.
Olivia Stoker:
I play Bunny Flingus who is Artie’s mistress. It’s really been an amazing process. We have these
amazing professional
Olivia Stoker:
designers; the whole design team is professional and obviously we’re in a professional theater,
and we have the Lewis Center and the Theater Department supporting us, and as you can tell, this is just an
Olivia Stoker:
incredible set. And everything, everything from the details of the props to
sound cues and smoke…
Brad Baron:
…it’s so much bigger than just us.
This is 'The House of Blue Leaves,' and we open Friday, March 25th at 8PM,
Brad Baron:
and we run for two weekends in the Berlind Theater at Princeton University. It’s a hilarious
dark comedy written by John Guare and we’re really excited to share it with all of you.
Brad Baron [singing]:
“Where is the Devil in Evelyn, What’s it doing in Angela’s eyes?
Evelyn is heavenly, But Angela’s in a devil’s disguise.”